welcome back I was just chugging through
the Harry math of this problem which I
think we're almost done but as I was
saying we're just simplifying this and
we have 25 times sine squared of 15 plus
cosine squared of 15 and I said well
that's an identity right I remember I
undistributed this 25 so sine squared
plus cosine squared of the same angle is
1 so I can simplify this 2 and I will
now change colors just to be arbitrary
so 25 plus 100 minus 100 cosine of 15
degrees and this is what M Squared is
equal to and I used the variable M
because it stands for nothing relevant
to this problem and that equals 125
minus 100 cosine of 15 degrees now I
have to use a calculator if I want to
get a real answer but the area the the
possibility for error is much lower now
that I've hopefully simplified it so I
could use my calculator and let's see
the cosine of 15 degrees cosine of 15
degrees I'll write that down here you
can just use a calculator or table to
figure that out
it is equal to 0.96 0.965 9 3 9 3 so
this term would be 125 minus 100 times
this right so what's 100 times this well
that's just minus ninety six point five
nine three right I just 100 times the
cosine of 15 degrees and now let me use
the trusty calculator to figure out what
that is so if I say 125 minus ninety six
point five nine three I get twenty eight
point four oh seven so I have M Squared
is equal to twenty eight point four oh
seven and so M is equal to the square
root of that is going to be 5 point
something right square root five point
three to nine a so five point three
three
M is equal to five point three three and
we're done the poor guy he's got to
figure out the right direction to go and
he probably has to think about the
current and all of that but he hasn't
asked us that question so we won't
answer it so but all he has left to go
is five point three three miles so he's
only has to go an extra point three
three miles and he would have had he had
gone in in the right direction from the
get-go hopefully that makes some sense
if it doesn't well not much I can do but
maybe you can and re-watch this video
have fun